harper's magazine in this morning's
washington post in the front page
david broder writes the disaster that
has struck walter f mondale in the past
week is one of the greatest and least
predicted
implosions of modern u.s political
history never has a front runner fallen
with more sickening
speed your reaction
my reaction is that the he was a
frontrunner only in terms of the media
and that there was never any other
evidence to suggest that he was a
frontrunner and so that
what broder is saying is that he was
wrong that's to say that he wrote it was
wrong and
sort of dressing it up with
large words i think
but i i i think it's very funny i mean
you could go back and compare some of mr
broder's columns and other people's
columns three or four months ago about
the juggernaut of mondale but it was it
was a press uh
bloom
lou lapham is the editor of this
publication brand spanking new new type
new everything we're going to talk a
little bit about why
as we go through this hour this is the
march edition two bucks on the newsstand
and uh
question to you quickly
what what's the basic reason for
restructuring harpers
the
to make it uh survive
essentially i mean it's been redesigned
in order to
i hope make it more
appealing and more accessible to larger
numbers of people and it cannot live on
a subsidy it has to exist in the market
and i think that
design and
content has more chance of
surviving in a market than the
previous design from 1976 to 1981 you
were the editor of harper's and you left
for a while why why are you back now
i was back because the mag after i left
the magazine got itself in a little i
mean the
renewal rates began to drop away and the
management
asked me to come back and try it again
and i said i'd do that on the condition
that i could
change it around what do you think it's
the most significant change you've made
in this magazine
the most significant change is is the uh
reading section and the in the front of
it there are about 20 odd pages of
bits and pieces of things picked up from
the
surrounding
publishing not that part of it right
what you remember yeah the first page
not the first page the that sort of this
thing that's the index now after that
we'll get there
this these these are the next 20 pages
and that
it puts
into the conversation
elements from other aspects of the press
that happens to be a speech by pat
moynihan that was not at all covered in
the
media at all it was a speech about
terrorism there's also a speech in there
from
edwin bennett williams there's a there
there are readings taken from
uh harvard business review from foreign
press from the
nouvelle observatory in france there are
cartoons picked up from our own media
there are lists there are all kinds of
things it's a mosaic of the of what's
going on in
lots of other places not ordinarily
found in the uh
run of the media i personally just found
that i'm gonna go back and see if i can
find it now that uh you mentioned it
this
this uh that's also a new thing yeah
this lit this
people like to read lists i think people
are fascinated with lis that's an index
and that takes
40 odd facts out of the
again out of the public domain and puts
them in a in a sequence every month
they'll be different every month so
i think they're interesting to read the
first one for example gives you the
total hours of television watched in
american households in 1983 and it's 213
billion
and the second one is
the number of american students who
scored perfect scores on the sats in the
same year and the number is four
the number of wars in 1983 41 41 and
then there's another thing where it says
that there are
2 500 astronomers in the united states
but there are 10 000 astrologers
and then there's one that suggests
says that there are
16 000 movie theaters in the united
states but 114 000 movie theaters in the
soviet union
and people can do with i mean their
editorial writers all over the country
i'm sure would
find out a
great pile of scrap out of which to make
uh columns
lou lapham also writes a column and is
syndicated in some of america's
newspapers i want to go back to our
original discussion when we opened up
here here's don campbell writes in this
morning's usa today we talked you said
that the
mondale candidacy was a media phenomena
let me read what he says this morning
i'm in trouble here
as to heart at this point he is almost
totally a media phenomenon although the
voters in tiny new hampshire got a close
look at him the national electorate has
only a vague impression of who hart is
the media that glamorized heart
eventually will scrutinize his personal
and political history and no doubt harp
on the question of whether hart's new
ideas are all that new
well that's i guess that heart's a media
phenomenon too but
at least he's
one in new hampshire and in maine and in
iowa
not in iowa but he did much better in
iowa than they expected to so
in many ways of course all the
candidates are media phenomenon i mean
president reagan is a great
triumph of the media as you know
so that
my point about
about mondale was that the media had
been predicting and predicting and
predicting that he was saying that he
was an unstoppable that there was no
other candidate in the race
be really on the basis of of not very
much evidence and
they find themselves surprised when uh
it vanishes now in this morning's
washington post on the op-ed page
a couple of columns here one over here
by evans and novak at jfk image
to middle-aged voters and politically
sensitive dixie hearts conscious
evocation
of john kennedy has become a striking
even glaring part of the senator's
message quote frankly i think he has
studied the jfk political culture his
mannerisms and his speaking style
alabama state representative alvin
holmes told us if he catches on i tell
you he'll be hard to stop do you agree
with that
um
i'm not sure i agree with that i
don't think that these things are are
i don't think you can replicate kennedy
any more than
somebody could replicate carter or
reagan or johnson i
in
hindsight sometimes looks easy to say
that but
i think hart will have to demonstrate
something that pertains to himself
where they can be identified as as hard
rather than as a copy of kennedy let me
show you something in the new york times
frank lynn writes
except for the lack of humor the kennedy
image carries over to the heart speaking
style there are the short choppy
sentences the fist pumping the senator
acknowledged several weeks ago that
theodore sorensen a kennedy speechwriter
who is now a new york lawyer helped
shape major speeches mr sorenson is a
national co-chairman of the heart
campaign do we long to bring back the
kennedy image and the kennedy style of
politics
i guess some of us do some of us would
like to have
that feeling of excitement or hope or of
glamour that seemed to attach to to
jack kennedy's presidency and maybe they
can
attach it to a heart
the they tried to attach it if you
remember to
to carter it didn't without without any
success at all it didn't work maybe it
will work with this well sure there's
always a longing for
the romance the glamour the
youthful vigor of politics that's a
pretty much of a
general condition
harper's magazine
is changing and more philosophical a lot
more in-depth articles speeches and
things you're talking about do you
intend to play a role in this election
campaign
if you do how
no we're not we're not well
we have a number of
fine
essays commissioned and we'll run a a
forum i think the magazine now has a
format which allows for a forum
discussion in the center of it anywhere
from 12 to 16 pages long
and what we'll probably do is in in the
july or
august issues during the time of the
convention
we will solicit
we will ask 15 or
20 people around the country to write
acceptance speeches as if they were
accepting a nomination and these would
be people
not necessarily professional politicians
and to try and see if they could
come up with a set of ideas that were
genuinely new as opposed to i'm afraid
mr hart's ideas which i doubt very much
whether they're new but i would ask
people
not having to campaign for the
labor vote or for the
milk lobby or for whatever
special interest they
they need to address
to simply
write down what they would do with if
you know what they thought was the best
thing to do for them for their country
as a as a whole
and i would think that if we get lucky
and we get the right
10 or 12 people and respond to that that
would be a very
interesting counterpoint to the rhetoric
that will be taking place
both at the republican and democratic
conventions and the march issue does
america still exist it opens up
on a whole series of uh
i guess you would call them short
articles or short
essays
um what are you trying to get at here
what i'm trying to get out there is uh
the idea of the american
what is the american idea in other words
are we simply a nation that that of is
it just a motley collection of private
purposes where people can
follow their own bent do their own thing
etc etc or is there some larger
notion of a
republic a community a nation which
would require
a kind of
allegiance to a
recognizable set of public myths you see
what i'm saying or standards or ideals
[Music]
and i asked the question
we posed that question and we asked it
to
again
people of
very differing
political views robert nisbet is a man
sometimes identified certainly leaning
toward the right
but also phillip berrigan who would be
more and michael harrington who would be
more toward the left
also to a writer
a very popular writer on the one hand
named lewis lemour
and on the other hand a
a novelist named robert stone
and so he tried this question on a
number of people
to see what
in 1984
what we could say about
patriotism or a national ideal and and
what's remarkable about those various
essays is their optimism
the
no matter how critical
some of these people feel
obliged to be in their remarks they they
come back to a very strong feeling that
the united states is a coherent
idea as well as a place and to me it was
an exciting uh proposition in this
morning's washington post in the style
section jonathan yardley writes
it's a little bit long but i want to get
to get it all on the table here and get
your response to it the vote projections
they're talking about the networks exist
not to inform us out there in the
audience but to inflate the
institutional egos of the network news
organizations to prove that cbs is
faster than nbc that abc
has better graphics than cbs that nbc
has more skillful posters than abc than
abc it is a philosophy of journalism the
essence of which is watch what we do not
what we report
this narcissistic view which is by no
means limited to television news has
much to do with the public's hostility
to and distrust to the press what it
says to the public is you don't matter
we matter your votes don't count our
votes count the vote projections
masquerade as news but they're really
just another way for the press to tell
itself how wonderful and how important
it is small wonder the public feels
otherwise your reaction i agree with
that i i think one of the
i think there is a certain kind of
resentment in the country against
or toward the media toward the press and
i think it's based on the
presumption of the
media
it's
attitude more than it's i don't think
people care
that newspapers make mistakes or the
journalists are wrong i think what they
what irritates them is that the is the
pretension of uh omniscience or the uh
the sense that uh somehow the uh
members of the media are
grand signier and that you know nobles
that must be courted and flattered for
their good opinion and i do think they
do compete among themselves
on the grounds that mr yardley
remarks
harper's
134 years old the
oldest monthly magazine in america
two dollars on the newsstand
you go down a lot of things here about
the magazine that are interesting and
one thing that just caught my eye is
harper's advisory board
what impact does walter cronkite as a
member of the harper's advisory board
have on the new magazine
none so far the advisory board simply
means people that i can call on the
telephone and
if you see there's not only mr cronkite
but there's mr
george ball and a fellow named heinz
pagels who's a physicist and
president of the
american academy of sciences in new york
city and a man named colonel harry
summers who's a
teacher's uh doctrine at the army work
college
as well as norman lear who's a
television producer in
hollywood and what it means is that if i
have a question of some kind or if i
want to
call somebody and ask what's going on
that's interesting
that the magazine should pursue
these men i i can pick up the phone
and they'll
you know discuss it with me for a while
here's what the new harpers looks like
our first call the morning for lou
lappam the editor of this publication is
from charleston west virginia go ahead
please
well first of all i'd like to say thanks
and i'd like to say that in years past
i've enjoyed reading harper's especially
researching
harper's through their very early issues
to get some information about earlier
trends whatever
my question is about one of the
subtitles in his magazine about
durability of democracy
i see a growing trend in the country
today away from
liberalism back to conservativism it's
kind of like a child picking out on ice
cream and now it's gone the other way
and
my biggest fear is whether or not
democracy is durable enough to stand
religion
and i mean in the exact sense because i
see religion as a doctrine for
politics more so than a spiritual
doctrine and i see it coming into the
fabric in the foundation of the country
increasingly
and
i'm really afraid that democracy or
democratic freedoms individual freedoms
will not be able to survive
under this new conservative wave of
religionism
i'm wondering his comments let me ask
you at that point what where do you
stand on this debate that's starting
today in the senate and the house
over the prayer amendment
well i believe in the strict
constitutionality of separation of
church and state
i don't think there should be any laws
passed to impede
the private
prayer
but i don't believe that religion and
state should ever mix and i see
with president reagan in there this
abortion issue and and other issues that
are tied to religion
as a strong
threat to democracy and i don't believe
that with democratic majority rule that
individual freedoms are going to be able
to allow to survive in this country all
right sir thank you a lot for the call
appreciate it mr lapham
i agree with that gentleman i i take the
same position that he takes on the
school prayer and the
as far as the religionism
uh threatening democracy i think that
that's um
so i think that but i think that's not
only in the united states
but i think that's in the in the world
at large if you look at the
if you look at the
results in poland where we have an
immense
upsurge in in the catholicism if you
look at the same thing in south america
where i believe the numbers are
something
like the
double of
communicants in the catholic church
throughout latin america in the last 10
years you look at the same
sort of fundamentalism
in islam not only in in
iran but also in
other countries in the
middle east
and i think you're seeing a phenomenon
that's taking also by the way it's true
in in the in the eastern bloc nations of
europe there was a
a large resurgent of resurgence of
christianity or at least an interest in
it in east germany so that last one of
the things in our index
in that list that you had was that the
last year was a
celebration of martin luther's birthday
there were 150 books published on the
subject in east germany and only 50
published in west germany so that i
think what he's
uh
what the gentleman is saying is that
this is
this is true
worldwide i mean
and the
real question is whether a
secular
democratic republican form of government
based on experience and on
experiment and on reason
can withstand the the
hectic and frenzied
emotional appeals
to some
transcendental truth
bloomington illinois good morning
you're on the air bloomington go ahead
please yes good morning
i have a
question
for the guest that is concerning more
and more people here in central illinois
and that is a possibility of a
constitutional convention
two-thirds of the states must
vote for one at the present time
only two more states are required
and
six are more or less jockeying for this
so-called honor
being the last two to vote for
constitutional convention
noah's
sixth day
before
the
vote has passed in the first house
and is only waiting for a change of
wording
to be passed in the second house
does the guest
think first that the constitutional
convention may open up a whole bag of
worms
it is the [ __ ] supposedly to be
called for the purpose of a
voting or changing constitution
but we can have a balanced budget which
is probably
only utopia and lastly now hang up then
my center uh dixon one of the center's
offices told me that
senator reagan is encouraging a
constitutional convention
representative bob michael's officer
says visit congress will stop how can
the congress stop the constitutional
convention okay all right sir thanks for
the call mr lapham
i will i would be uh reluctant to uh
open up a constitutional convention i
think the constitution as it stands is
an extremely
useful and flexible
document and that it's been as as you
know it's been changed amended
interpreted in various ways
throughout
the last
200 years and
it can be made to do
what
a majority or what a
this the sentiment in the country wants
it to do i now have to open it up to a
convention and to try to codify
all of the
imperfections or to try to to make laws
that will rectify all of the
imperfections in the present system
i think would be uh
a mistake i i feel the way the confucius
once said that as the laws multiply the
civilization decays
and i i i tend to feel that the fewer
the laws and the and the simpler
and the more flexible
the more effective they are and i also i
agree with you that a balanced budget
strikes me as a utopian
notion
particularly given the present deficit
and the likelihood that that deficit
will
grow over the next
10
or certainly in the foreseeable future
lou lappam is there anybody today in
american politics that you
respect and could vote for for the
presidency i could vote for mcgovern
i myself yeah i respect my government
and
of the present candidates that would be
the
the man that i would
be most drawn to second choice
again of the of the present
people i
probably would be i'm glen i'm i'm also
drawn to
cedar rapids good morning
hello you're on the air go ahead please
uh hello i
i just wanted to say that uh the news
media is arrogant
and uh like he just said he agreed with
all this
those things that carl are phoned in
about well america is a religious
country we
we stop being religious
uh we stop being great as winston
churchill said as long as america's
greatest
uh good it'll stay great
and when it ceases to be good it'll
cease to be great well if we get
if we take an opinion against prayer in
schools
for abortion
uh for all those uh liberal ideas and
unpatriotic another thing in the news
media this seems to
take uh put
communist russia on an equal ground with
the united states of america two
superpowers where they don't have any
patriotism uh standing up for their own
country and i i have a suspicion against
the media it doesn't seem to be for
america it is unpatriotic it doesn't go
for
uh salutes the flag it doesn't do it say
anything to stand up for this country it
gives equal
equal time and equal greatness to
communist countries such as russia which
is about to take over the world and it's
very pretty well done us with the help
of our news media all right carter thank
you mr lapham your response
well my response is i i i don't think
that the media is is unpatriotic i i
think nor do i think they give equal
time by any means to the
soviet union if you look through the
new york times in any given day or any
other newspaper or any television
whatever aspect the media you want to
look at i'm sure you'll find that the
overwhelming amount of the
space and the
time is devoted to the united states not
to the soviet union
um
i've met very few if any uh american
people
people in the american media who would
be even remotely communist in their
beliefs or thoughts as far as this
prayer is concerned i agree with the
woman that the the the
only way a democracy can work and this
was pointed out by jefferson and by
a number of other
people who wrote wrote the constitution
was that it requires
what jefferson referred to as virtue
in other words
if the democracy can be is let to
deteriorate into
a rapacious
grasping or an exaggeration of
individualism which becomes merely
nothing more than a competing series of
ambitions and greed
then yes then the system breaks down but
i don't think you can codify the the
religious um
attitude or or or virtuous attitude in
the forms of government
the founding fathers could assume
a widespread level of christian faith in
the united states
in the late 18th century
now
but they had the wisdom not to try to
put that into the law or into the
political structure
and i think
they were correct in that
phoenix arizona good morning
good morning
i hope i can hear you i called up about
two months ago and it's very difficult
to hear you
um i'd like to make two statements and
then i'll hang up so i can hear you
uh
number one i believe a woman called up
uh quite a few months ago asking for
uh people representing
at that time the american opinion and
review of the news and you said that you
didn't you did not um
usually use
magazine editors or people representing
them
that's number one wait wait wait wait
wait we have i didn't say that at all i
said that that uh
they their leadership
at the time that the lady called was the
only one that could speak for the
organization we have since contacted the
john birch society and asked them when
the whole operation i think is out of
boston i'm not sure about that but when
the editor who is heads up the
review of the news is available in
washington he'll be on this program it's
a very small organization you've got to
understand that we did follow up and
we'd be glad to have whoever is the
editor of reviewing the news right here
like mr lapland okay well uh that's fair
because even though it
certainly has a definite opinion now the
other thing is about the school prayers
i've been following education now since
1964
having um
three sons of mine in school and there
had been a difference between the two
older ones and the younger one
once and i don't think as much as i'm
for prayer
i don't think prayer is going to help
the humanistic philosophy of the public
schools you have to really
delve into the
public school today and see the courses
that they're being taken that are uh
being given to the children to the uh
negativism
of the uh the whole philosophy
of what they're being um asked to
assimilate and
i doubt that a little prayer
giving given by are some of these uh
liberal humanistic uh teachers
uh i think it's going to really um
possibly ridicule uh religion uh you
know which would be a shame
uh but on wednesday um
public schools entirely you know right
from the uh ground up and have the
parents uh choose a school of their
choice and then
pay for it themselves
at this point even though i am a product
of public school
education and i was fortunate and two of
my friends were
that
um
for many many years now
i don't think there's anything worth
salvaging in the public schools except
uh by the uh grace of god there would be
a um a teacher that
would be so inclined us to spare these
children uh of many of the uh garbage
that's being given them thank you all
right phoenix thank you mr lapham
well i i like the woman's point that i
would be nice if the debate this morning
if the
the usa today that you've been
discussing says emotional debate to
start in congress and you've mentioned
to me the possibility of filibuster and
dramatic
events and it would be
to my mind it would be more
hopeful if the if that those terms were
used about
the course of instruction in public
schools or the nature of an american
education or about the
uh the curriculum or about how could we
improve what's being taught or how can
we raise the level of the salaries of
teachers and so on and if that was the
emotional debate i would be much more
encouraged than i would be than i am to
see it as an argument as to pray or not
to pray lou lapham is the editor of this
publication and it's a whole new
magazine this is this the first issue
that it changes yeah that's the first of
the
new
issues what the what day of the month is
this printed so it comes out like this
march issue when one of the first
come off the
printing presses that first came off the
printing presses
almost uh
a month ago it comes off we we work as
many magazines do we work
a cycle which is
the actual magazine
is printed a month before of it before
its cover date the reason for that is
that
it takes that amount of time to
ship it around the country and have it
placed on newsstands in time for
the proper month
we have a very busy week for you here at
c-span and uh because the the call-in
shows for the rest of the day will be
canceled we might want to point out a
number of things that you ought to put
in your schedule book uh the a group of
uh matter of fact i think the wire
service here says
about one o'clock uh house republican
leader robert michael kicks off around
the clock house session uh which
involves special order periods that go
until about nine o'clock tomorrow
morning um
tomorrow night for instance we'll be at
the national press club for a salute to
eric severide you'll see a lot of media
folks
we have the conservative republicans and
republicans today on the house floor all
day the media tomorrow night from the
press club and then a salute to tip
o'neill speaker of the house on
wednesday night and then we go to
florida on thursday so we've got a busy
week for you let's go back to the phone
for lou lappum rochester new york good
morning
good morning i'd like to speak about
school prayer but first i'd like to make
a statement about mr mondale and his
heart it'll be very brief
uh
mr mondale who was
made to be the leader
of the democratic party or the front
runner should i say by the news media
uh he he dresses like you know a
republican he's all
plush in place not a hair out of place
he speaks in expensive looking
surroundings never among the people with
his hair flying like mr
mr um
heart
the heart does give a sort of a john
kennedy type image but images is only
images and a person has to sell himself
and i think that's the problem with mr
mondale he's always
been unable to sell himself uh his views
and that's my opinion about that what i
want to talk about is school prayer
the question that's never been asked
and when they're talking about prayer is
god
you know they're saying put prayer in
school praying school you know god is in
school you don't need a prayer to put
god in school i can't see the importance
of a prayer in school
may god it's not going to make a
difference in their education it's not
going to make a difference in the school
you have prayers and catholic schools
and their problems
one of the arguments that is brought up
from time to time is that you need to
verbalize out loud a prayer in order to
have it be effective at all you do not
agree with that
no it doesn't work in catholic schools
uh
you you say a prayer you say a prayer it
lasts two minutes
at the most and
what can be accomplished in two minutes
really
uh but the important thing is you look
at television prayers big business i
mean well religion is big business you
have more religious programs on
television you have anything
uh you have around the clock
relationship 700 club that's religion
everywhere you turn your television and
mr reagan who
i don't even know what the nomination he
is i don't think he even goes to church
he puts on his plaid shirt and chopped
wood and makes his speeches on sundays
he knows how to get out and use the
people he's an actor you go to a movie
you see a real tear-jerker so reagan
knows how to
come on to the people who use his acting
ability you never want to ask her as an
actor but he's winning one as president
he comes on and he tells people about
prayer because he takes the sympathy he
takes
what a person is dear dearest to and he
uses it all right sir let me let mr
lapin respond to that because
over the weekend the conservative
political action conference was held
here in washington and the headline that
comes out in the washington times this
morning by george archibald at least the
articles by george archibald
conservatives i reagan coattails
and there's a discussion in here about
the conservatives feeling a little bit
better about mr reagan assess
the reagan presidency for us
well i don't think the reagan presidency
is a conservative presidency i mean the
uh i know that's what's said but i don't
i mean
mr reagan would not fit my definition of
a conservative at all nor would the
gentlemen that are
backing him on the on the conservative
on the supposedly conservative side the
conservative
reagan strikes me as a more of a radical
he reminds me in many ways of he reminds
me more of
jack kennedy than hart reminds me of
jack kennedy in the sense that
he is for a uh an aggressive uh
vigorous uh
changing of of the purposes of
government he doesn't strike me as a man
who
wants to
conserve the
fundamental values of the american
constitution
he doesn't strike me as a man who knows
very much of anything about american
history
i don't think he has a
a deep or profound love for the for the
past
uh
i think he's an agitator or at least
he's surrounded by people who want to
agitate and change things which is not
the conservative temperament
so that
what i i do not think that that this
this fall we are going to have a test of
uh
conservativism i don't think we've seen
it in this country paul weirich the
director of the committee for the
survival of a free congress is quoted in
this article this morning in the
washington times quote as conservatives
we kid ourselves we think ronald
reagan's re-election will bring major
gains for the conservative movement do
you
agree well i don't know what uh means by
the conservative movement i don't know
what he means by gains the uh
uh
the conservative if you take the proper
definition of the word is is to is to
conserve and
and preserve and it isn't usually
interested in gains for movements i mean
the whole idea of a conservative
movement is a contradiction in terms
richland washington good morning you're
on with louis lapham harper's magazine
yes good morning hi
um
i'd just like to make a statement on
this um
i think i've got an echo here can you
hang on a minute sure please turn down
your television set because you do get a
delay
go ahead richland
okay um
i think if
we really look at what our founding
fathers uh
taught and put in our constitution in
the separation of church and state
they say church and state as two nouns
so that no one church could take over
the government like they had done in the
older countries it was not a separation
of religion and state
and i think this is where
our supreme courts and our uh people
have made a big mistake in this
feeling it's been the later years i
think within the last 20 or 30 years
that the supreme court
turned this into keeping religions out
of schools
instead of
having a separation of the church and
state like our founding fathers
thought they were very religious men
and i'd just like to read this one
sentence here by thomas jefferson if i
could
he said can the liberties of a nation be
thought secure
when we have removed their only firm
basis a conviction in the minds of the
people that these liberties are of the
gift of god
that they are not to be violated but
with his wrath
and so i just appreciate that thank you
all right thank you mr lapham if um the
founding fathers came back and
jumped right in the middle of what's
going on right now what do you think
their reaction would be
um
that's a broad statement i mean
everybody thought their shock and
surprise i'm sure because the uh
as as as that woman just said and this
and and
as another woman said earlier on this
show the
founding fathers did assume
a
religious
if not
dogma at least temperament and they
understood that that
for the country to work it required a
degree of virtue and an ability to
restrain oneself something that
that that would check the uh
democratic impulse to
uh toward on right on
unparalleled ambition and greed
and without that kind of uh
moral check
um
the you the country is always at the
uh
in the
at least runs the danger of of
carrying its common fragrance fabric
into shreds what are you right about in
this week's this
issue in that yes
that's about
the worship of high technology
and uh
the the sub the use of high technology
as a kind of magical
um
divine
substitution for religion as a matter of
fact
salisbury south carolina go ahead please
north carolina oh i'm sorry sorry
good morning
brian i'd like to make a comment i think
on school prayer
i feel that we already have the right to
uh the freedom of religion i don't think
the constitution says freedom from
religion and i don't think it's
necessary
that to pray out loud you can pray
anywhere and one caller stated that god
is everywhere
and i prayed in school many times and my
grandson was punished one day for
sleeping in school
and he was actually saying a little
prayer to help him get through a test
but nothing we we didn't say anything
about it but he has that right
and uh
i don't care who the judge is or federal
judges rules that you don't we have
freedom of religion and that separation
of church and state
i think means that
you know they
shouldn't support the churches um
and and people not contribute to the
churches i think there's a
misunderstanding entirely i think our
founding fathers
didn't mean what they uh the way they
understand it now let me ask you a
caller down in north carolina do you
find yourself uh
in agreement with your friends or in
disagreement with your friends on this
issue well most of them feel the same
way i do that
my friends anyway i'm a democrat
and i feel that we
uh
my whole family all believe that you can
pray anywhere
anytime
and a real christian does that and you
don't have to pray out loud the bible
says you can go in
in the closet and and not make a show of
it not supposed to do that and i don't
think anybody ought to use religion it's
a political issue all right thank you
let me ask in that note on that note in
this morning's philadelphia inquirer
here's one of an article that's
published in almost all the papers
jackson meets with jewish group in
framingham massachusetts um pulling out
probably the most inflammatory quote in
the article just to get your response to
whether or not this whole is this a
religious
movement and an inner twangling of uh
intermingling of you know religion and
state and all that
this is a quote uh mr jackson spoke to a
group of jewish folks
and it doesn't say
where i don't base statement i breathe
excuse me rene breath you are an
anti-semite yourself this is what
someone in the audience said you are a
jew hater
taking that language and that event
assess for us what you think is going on
between the reverend jackson and the
jewish community
well a certain
i guess bitterness of feeling on the
part of the jewish community because of
jackson as you know a couple of
a week ago or two weeks ago whatever it
was was quoted as as referring to
jews as hymies or new york is jaime town
and this set off a flurry of uh uh
reaction in in the jewish community and
i don't
think that that's a particular i don't
think that's
a religious question so much as it is a
racial question and you and
it and you work up the emotions and the
biases and the prejudices it's around
the uh
the racial
um
divisions and okay the jews of course
are particularly uh
sensitive on this subject
and
so are the blacks and and the
combination of the sensitivities is what
you see in that newspaper story who owns
harper's magazine now
the harpers magazine foundation owns it
which is a
was the magazine went out of business
about three years ago and the former
owners the minneapolis star and harold
starring tribune company
sold the magazine to the macarthur
foundation in chicago and the macarthur
foundation in chicago established
something called the harpers magazine
foundation and endowed it
with a gift of money what's your
circulation
a hundred and forty thousand at the
moment going up or down i think it's
going up right now
palm beach california go ahead please
yes um another peter's caller and
several points been brought up about
prayer in the schools
i know when i was in uh college uh back
in georgia and early 60s we were
required to go to church on sunday
and there was not an episcopal church in
the area and i was forced to go to a
catholic church but we all had to go to
church
how do they pro-propose changes
uh implement protection from having
overzealous religious groups
enforcing their viewpoint in the prayers
that will take place in the schools i
think the main issue is not whether it's
going to be prayer in the truth or not
of whether or not one particular group
is going to
again uh in this if one looks around the
world today they'll see an uprise of
religious fundamentalism all over the
world in ireland the middle east and in
many cases united states how are people
going to be protected
that's my main question all right all
right sir thank you there are three
different resolutions as a matter of
fact the usa today does a good job here
on the front page joint resolution 73
212 and 218 these are all being debated
in the senate this week the house does
not have this issue on the floor
what you will see this afternoon
is a group of republicans taking up a
special order period and going around
the clock
i guess to discuss the main fact that
it's not on the floor and you want can
you address what the gentleman from palm
beach california
asked about
yeah again i think he has a point i
think everybody has come back it's like
the woman in north carolina i mean
if a certain
tone is established
no matter how
all of these resolutions talk about
voluntary they all use the word
voluntary but
in certain places of course it won't
seem voluntary i mean as you you know
depends on the
local circumstance it depends on what
the
where the school is in in what kind of a
neighborhood and and what the uh agenda
is of that uh community or that school
and it can be used as a in a way that if
one did not pray one would be made to
feel uh somehow
um
less uh
perfect uh not only in the eyes of god
but in the eyes of one's
fellow students in school authorities
and i think that's the point that the
gentleman is making and i think it's the
point that the
prior caller is also making louis
slapham is a graduate of yale in 1956
and
studied english and history
we've got about 12 minutes to go but my
point out for those of you who are
anxiously awaiting the
what we expected to be the concluding
day of the ed meese hearings the
confirmation hearings to be attorney
general they have been postponed until
12 30 p.m east coast time which means
that we will not be able to bring them
to you live today because we'll be to
the floor of the house at noon and those
will have to be brought to you on tape
we will not be able to bring them to you
tonight because uh it appears that the
house floor will be active all night
long and that means we have canceled our
five o'clock and our nine o'clock
call-in show and therefore we'll have to
wait until tomorrow or beyond to bring
you those hearings where our cameras are
there cranford new jersey you're on with
lou lapham go ahead please uh yes good
morning my comment is in regards to
president reagan um
i don't know personally whether i am a
left or right or a conservative or
democrat or republican
but i do want to say that i
respect the president in regards to the
fact that he's got enough guts in his
position to make a stance on issues
whether they be religious or not
there's a lot of times that i don't
agree with his opinion
but like one caller stated he is an
actor we've had a lot of people attempt
to be actors in the office and i think
it's about time that we've got a
professional in there
my comment in regards to his stance on
prayer in school and abortion
again i i think that in his position
that it's
it's unbelievable to me that the man
would be able to speak on an issue of
any kind
that is so debated throughout our
country religion and schools scares me
to a point because of the
cult factor that has gone into america
today and the fear that young people
have about saying they're religious or
not religious and this to a point uh
frightens me um when asking several kids
the other day whether they were
religious or not that were babysitting
for me
they were a little hesitant to say
whether they were or not and ask me if
it made a difference
i think the prayer in school is going to
be there whether there's rules against
it or rules for it or not like the woman
from north carolina said
i think that it's a big part of our
forefathers foundings because they were
religious and your comment on what would
they do if they were back here today um
if they ever got through the punk rock
music and the disco themes um i think
yes probably they would jump back into
their graves and hope not to be woken up
for about another hundred years but i
did want to say that i do respect the
president for his issues and like myself
there's a lot of things i don't agree
with what i've said uh today tomorrow so
he'll have my vote the next time he runs
all right thanks for the call mr laffy
your response to that woman's call well
i
i
like what she said but i'm i'm also
surprised brian that you didn't mention
there's another column in the papers
this morning and it's which addresses
this whole question which is mr
sapphire's column in the times
which runs on the editorial page and he
he's talking about the
situation in lebanon
and he says the abandonment of the
christians of lebanon by christendom is
one of the phenomena of our time
and he goes on to say that in the cradle
of civilization christianity is dying
out and christians elsewhere do not seem
to care
now he could be writing in the 12th
century he's talking what he's talking
about here is essentially a crusade and
he casts around the world for who will
help the christians in
lebanon will it be
the united states no will it be the pope
no and so forth but he's talking about
this in a very
uh we go back in a very religious terms
that it they somehow christendom the
west owes it to to the faithful
marionite christians in lebanon to
rescue them from the infidel heathen
islamic
mob essentially is what he's saying
now that goes back to the question asked
by the very first caller
almost an hour ago who's talking about
the rise of religious
feeling in the world at large and uh so
this to my mind is another element of
the
or another facet of the same phenomenon
that is showing up in the school prayer
debate today
lou lapham we go out to the far west
again tempe arizona go ahead please
uh
hello go ahead sir
uh i would just like to comment on mr
lapham's remark that the new york times
presents a
unbiased
attitude towards
the news
i think that's
ingenuous that to say the least i've
lived in new york for many many years
and i think i probably
uh
uh
read the new york times
while mr uh lapham was in the knickers
and i recall mr durante and mr harold
denny and mr herbert and matthews
uh who were featured prominently in the
new york times
and i don't think they gave an unbiased
view
of the news and mr matthews in
particular
is as much responsible
for fidel castro being in
the position he is in as anyone in the
united states i'd like to hear mr
lapham's remarks mr lapin
i agree with the gentleman i don't think
i ever said that the times was unbiased
i think i said that the
i think i defended the media merely to
say that it was not unpatriotic
but the times is of course deeply biased
uh so are most newspapers so are are
most instruments of uh of the media
i mean i have written a number of uh
pieces and columns myself i'm on long
time on record as referring to the bias
of the time since particular
and i agree with him on about matthews
matthew's
together with some of the
together also of course with the with
the state department in in washington
uh
we felt it incumbent upon them to
support the noble
uprising of fidel castro and
it's uh
no i i hope i've never said that the
newspaper is unbiased watching iowa new
hampshire
maine
exit polls projections
uh pre-election polls is the media
looking powerful today or less powerful
than it was before this election started
in terms of how they influenced an
election
i think they're trying to it depends
what you mean by powerful i i think
they're trying to generate the kind of
excitement that we'll make headlines for
them we'll make news stories for them i
mean
next week we can be sure we will see on
the cover of newsweek uh yeah heart
we'll see heart now for a while it's
it's something to say
the media wants a horse race they they
want to have winners and losers they i
mean they they blew up the balloon of
blondel and then much to their surprise
uh to nobody else's surprise however i'm
sure the
heart wins now they'll try and see what
they can get out of that action for a
while but what they're interested in is
is
again as you pointed out in one of the
other columns is they're interested in
in in stories they're interested in
headlines they're interested in a race
it's a super bowl uh uh
a competition
and
to me what does the the victory of heart
says is that the democratic party is in
a true shambles
and uh that if they
if they if they're going to it means to
me that the the the chances are
rapidly diminishing against uh
president reagan naples florida you're
on with lou lapin my last call of
morning go ahead please
thank you i'd just like to make a couple
of short comments and then ask a
question could i ask you are you
watching this on cable uh yes i am in
naples florida yes i am well that's
brand new to us i'm glad to have you
thank you it's a little new to me too
and i enjoy you very much thank you go
ahead
well first of all i'd like to say i am a
republican and i would support reagan
however um i just want to make a couple
comments one is about everybody's
talking about the liberal press
and i think we do have a liberal press a
very liberal press but as far as i'm
concerned it's not a conspiracy as i've
observed
young people who are activistic and
liberal have a tendency to go into
journalism conservative young people
have a tendency to go into business and
teaching and that sort of thing so i
think we'll always be stuck with a
liberal press and i don't know whether
that's too bad as long as we realize it
on
the topic of religion i kind of got a
kick out of it that we couldn't stand uh
you know the religious movement today
because
as far as i could see a few years ago
they said god is dead and everybody was
leaving the churches we survived it now
they say
not well and living in america
everybody's going back to church i think
we'll survive that too
i mean i feel that our democracy is very
resilient about that type of thing
all right naples by the way just one
last question because i'm intrigued by
your call are you on the palmer
broadcasting system down there uh no i'm
on south florida cable tv south florida
cable tv
northern part of naples okay you're not
in the main city area no okay thanks uh
we're looking forward to getting on the
big system down there at some point but
we're delighted to have our naples
caller you have a minute sir to talk
about uh her final comment
well i i it's her idea of resiliency to
me is the great strength of the
system and i you know yes god was
pronounced dead
many years ago
freud i noticed was pronounced dead the
other day in new york
marx has been pronounced dead a couple
of times and it's uh
the intellectual
uh fashions
change uh
the i i do however think that the the
the tide is running very strongly toward
uh
some kind of religious
uh
expression or formal
explanation of what more and more people
begin to think of as a chaos of events
to which the secular religions marxism
freudianism
literary criticism and so on just simply
do not address our guest as always
interesting the editor of this
publication the new harpers
on your newsstands for the month of
march and continuing on he hopes i'm
sure forever our guest for the last hour
lou lapham who is the
editor of that publication we're
delighted to have him here and wish him
good luck with the new magazine and you
all have a good day
[Music]
so
[Music]
you